the Joe Rogan experience you think that
there's ever a project that could come
up that could tempt you into coming out
of retirement if somebody listens to you
on this podcast and realizes that a lot
of people [ __ ] with you while you worked
and said Rick we could do something
amazing just one more you know when I
first retired I would have said yes I
mean I I was leaving it open that I said
well maybe do designs or consult you
know I'm having way too much fun doing
my own thing you know I mean I I still
probably have the remains of my
Halloween makeup you know Halloween is a
big thing in my family mm-hmm I'm so
sorry they didn't send you a copy the
book it's gone I'll get it don't worry
I get it up put it on the Instagram oh
it's not so much about that I just say
if you're a fan I think you're liking oh
I am a feminine way by the response to
them yeah that's awesome when people I
mean they're loving it it's none of its
like 250 bucks you know but it's weighs
17 pounds it's two vow in with 2,000
pictures in it up from birth basically
in my last film and beyond you know in
my retirement but I don't know where I
was going with that what you asked me
well we were talking about possibly
coming out oh yeah mate you were saying
how much fun you're having right now no
I I seriously doubt that anything would
would get me back well that's great to
hear
well cuz it's not great because I would
love it if you did another movie but
it's great to hear that you're having
such a good time
well you know what I think say um when I
watched Breaking Bad mmm and Bryan
Cranston you know is such a great actor
but I said you know he would make a
great lunch Haney if they ever did a
remake of man of a thousand faces which
was the story of lon chaney he would be
a perfect person
you know besides being a great actor and
my wife sold me I went to a comic-con
and went to a panel that they had on
Breaking Bad and and we went back into
men Brian and and Vince and and I said
that to him you know hmm you know and I
don't know maybe if that happened you
know I I don't think anybody would go
see that film now how many people even
know lon chaney is and you know you know
but he to be able to recreate some of
those makeups on and
like that you know and if it was the
right people but again I I realized you
know I mean death became a more real
thing to me when my parents died and I
have friends that were younger than me
that are dead now one of my favorite
crew or my best guys and we just
recently passed 54 or something um and I
know there's an end in sight and I know
you know I've got our thright as my
cataracts I there's a limited time that
I have left to do the things I want to
do and I want to do what I want to do
you know what I mean and I don't want
the frustration in the stress
[Applause]